a VC kicked him said kicked him to the
curb no more now Fox is bringing him
back I guess after they saw how
successful Rosen was yeah no question I
think that was certainly according to
executives one of the deciding factors
which makes a lot of sense I mean Rosen
had this enormous enormous burst out of
the gate and that's because a lot of
people who voted for President Trump
we're looking at Roseanne they're saying
hey look somebody on TV who voted for
President Trump
well Last Man Standing was one of the
few conservative oriented shows on
television and then it went away and
it's smart for Fox or any other network
to bring back a show that might appeal
to half the country considering no other
show apparently does by the way it's
gonna be on Friday nights we have
Thursday Night Football and then Fox
gonna have that on Friday it was the
number two comedy in the country when
they mysteriously canceled it
yeah and because it was the number two
comedy in the country Ben that's why
people said are they canceling it
because he's a conservative well there's
no question that there's massive bias
inside Hollywood I wrote an entire book
where I went and interview people in
Hollywood producers writers actors
directors about exactly why there was so
little conservatism in Hollywood many of
them admitted to me on tape on the
record that there is open discrimination
in Hollywood against conservatives
there's an entire group of people out
here in LA called Friends of Abe
thousands and thousands of conservatives
who hide underground because they're
afraid that they'll be fired if they're
found out as people who didn't vote for
Hillary Clinton